in the short space of time we've been
looking tan inverse functions at all at
the moment we haven't really touched
calculus much except for one thing and
as either first or second most probably
the second lesson that we looked at
inverse functions generally speaking it
was one thing we looked at those
relevant to differentiation and inverse
functions like inverse trig functions
inverse functions in general do you
become all that that was what what what
property do okay so yeah we're looking
at gradient functions if you have an
increasing function its inverse will
also be increasing right it's called
cavity wall reverse we noticed that okay
but when it gets sounds like the nuts
and bolts of the algebra of the gradient
function what do we notice we have
examples I think it was because with
this right xq blood is one or something
like this okay if we call this one why
we notice if you've rephrased it if you
may x 2 subject the differentiator again
you wouldn't differentiate with respect
to X if you rearrange right what would
you differentiate with the better your
different shape visible to why because
I'm just doing this rememory I think
it's going to be something like this Y
is the dependent variable Y right so you
differentiate with respect to that
instead of X what was the relationship
that we got out after we got to the end
of this what did we conclude remember
yeah do you want to be x times DX with
you is very good so this is what we
concluded that we've kind of used this
result before when we're proving our
we're very the derivatives of the trig
functions in the first place but we kind
of did really prove it we just said hell
is kind of interesting these don't just
look like fractions they behave
fractions which makes sense because
that's where they came from right these
are all from first principles which just
rise over okay and therefore the other
way of stainless is to make either of
these a subject so for instance I could
say that DX on dy is just the reciprocal
of the derivative of the original
function does that make sense so we
looked at this and the import for that
for us was okay if you want to find a
function at its inverse and you want to
do some derivatives right if you look at
the inverse and if differentiating is
gross like it has chain rule or question
or something you want to avoid this is
kind of a nicely trick that you can take
right you just get the original
derivative and then you turn it upside
down that's nice okay but it's more
powerful now we're going to demonstrate
that today we have a look at these input
stream functions what adair only will we
do anything to do a trick right we have
three functions and you pretty much
always go in this order do you remember
why we go in this order like it's not
just arbitrary why is this the order
that makes it okay so you've gone all
over to calculus again before calculus
like just understanding likessee of
writing the triangles and in cyber-land
control the Tetra you always tell the
sign then we go to cause there we go too
thin what is college therefore again
this is the culprit of size so it
doesn't make sense to do anything with
this because it kind of depends on this
it gets its definition from Sian and of
course tam is defined by signing cars ok
so this broad it makes sense and we
always did this yesterday and earlier we
did in this order today actually get
start the end of the list I'm not going
to tell you why yeah I hope as we go
through it you realize oh okay makes
sense to start at the end this time but
let's consider okay consider y equals
10x now we're gonna start a toaster now
in order to get our inverse function
right why comes to EDX rather
dramatically fails the horizontal line
test so we restricted the domain wedding
we restrict it
we want it yeah we want it from negative
part two to plan to and we do not want
the boundaries right so I'm going to
place that restriction in there okay now
knowing that I can now say therefore x
is equal to tan inverse of Y does that
make sense only only having made this
domain restriction I can now say this
because this doesn't exist everywhere as
you put it up now if we want to know
therefore the derivative of this inverse
function now this is the perfect time
when this property is going to be useful
to us because I don't even know restart
on this I don't know however okay what
we're going to try and do first before
we dig into the yard while it is let's
try and make a prediction get another
color out with me in mathematics you
should always predict always make a
prediction you don't know what something
is going to be or in Lucan because if
you're right a banker prediction it
feels awesome you're like yes I'm really
spot but if you're wrong you get the
opportunity to question your assumptions
when you learn something okay so always
predict a boy's pretty so what you think
about this guy if um you've got a tan
inverse okay if tan inverse is what
you're differentiating all right let's
call this let's give it a name yes okay
let's call that F dash but now okay
let's just name that I could've got you
I suppose um this will make the things
those a little easier for you to refer
to you later what kinds of things can we
know can we guess we predict about f
dash cuz you know what tenemos looks
like you've got a picture of it in your
mind okay what kinds of things can you
think about I can think of at least one
two three things that we can predict
about the derivative based on what you
already know they don't want to start us
off yeah
okay so I've got it saw starts off
shallow and then it gets steeper and
that's like a shallow again ok so just
let me take a step back to say something
even more general that means that
broadly speaking it's an increasing
function do you agree with that so what
does that mean about f dash always
positive right f dash x is greater than
zero for all real values of x that's
because tan inverse is an increasing
function good that's something I know
what else can I predict yeah that's gay
yes or else yet riddim okay so I'm
expecting this should be I shouldn't
expect any restrictions on whatever the
derivative is going to be and I want any
holes in it because 10 inverse has no
holes ok so that's a good thing that's
not one of the things I originally
thought so now I've got four things
Brennan oh it's an even function ok I
got it now let's just think I that for
saying you might need you might need a
bit of a picture here now more than
something this in your head we know what
10 inverse looks like here's what I'm
looking at ok now what is it what does
it mean to be an even function that
means on the left-hand side and the
right hand side you're getting identical
behavior does that make sense and that
does check out rightly you look at the
opposite ends and you've got a very
shallow radio so a greater which
approaches zero right and then in the
Milky as I go in you're getting the same
kind of gradient right ok I'll go with
that I'll take that as arm actually
sorry we'll say it another way we have
algebra for how to stay if a function is
even right if I'm calling the derivative
f dash what can I say about f dash if it
is an even function
he calls yet very good ok now I'm going
to take that and there's a one of the
points I was thinking about is on the
specific values for which this is the
case right off at our extremities I mean
there's not very much interesting happen
to those stationary points nothing like
that add the extremities the limit as X
approaches plus and minus infinity of my
crazy function what is the look the
limits actually equal to something and
the answer is 0 right I'm approaching
these asymptotes which are horizontal
now one last thing then I'm going to
mention all of this is nice there's
actually one value that I actually know
the value of the derivative at that
point right when x equals 0 what am I
expecting the gradient today when x
equals so where am I looking I'm looking
here right working there and when this
came from was why was tan X and I know
what the grading of white aesthetics is
regulative then when you reflect across
y equals x what happens to that in this
case is going to be the same isn't it
like I mean don't venture others but if
you take a line I say wife was two
minutes and you reflect it across our
wife is explained to get the inverse
right the greedy used to be two and then
the gradient of the universe will be
what it would ready to be much better
it'll be a half right if I said I can't
take a grade of three then the grading
of the universe would be a third ok now
the grading of 10x regular TEDx at that
point is one so the grade of is inverse
will they also one so i can say f dash
at zero should be one do you agree with
that